con su pequeño cuerpo robusto sus
extremidades cortas y sus orejas grandes
y redondas el cual es una representación
icónica de australia un osito de
bolsillo que ahora está oficialmente en
peligro
los koalas han estado bajo presión
durante mucho tiempo debido al cambio
climático largos periodos de sequía y
por supuesto los incendios forestales
así que le pedí a los expertos
científicos que evaluarán la importancia
de incluir al koala en la lista de
especies en peligro de extinción hoy lo
es ahora es una cuestión prioritaria de
la conservación para este extraordinario
marsupiales externas símbolo del
ecosistema único de australia el cual ha
fue catalogado por primera vez como
vulnerable en la costa este del país
hace unos 10 años el animal está ahora
al borde de la extinción en esta zona
principalmente como una consecuencia de
los devastadores incendios forestales
que asolaron el país la ministra de
medioambiente de australia se
comprometió a invertir 50 millones de
dólares para restaurar los hábitats de
los koalas y para su protección pero
para los conservacionistas que el
anuncio llega demasiado tarde
según ellos si no se toman medidas en la
costa este que el koala podría
desaparecer totalmente para 2050